[Applause]
[Music]
that was you watching you watching you
that's my dream oh what a dream come
true for example I was watching the show
bones mm-hmm yeah I was watching the
show bones and then I hit the info
button and it said part of our Tuesday
night yes
it's still on block then I was watching
MasterChef junior yeah
MasterChef junior and then I hit the
info button and it said meet tomorrow's
hot-tempered cokeheads today I was
watching the dr. Oz Show yeah I hit the
info button and said very soon this will
be the only health care you'll be able
to afford I was watching this show and
II Finding Bigfoot oh yeah Finding
Bigfoot then I hit the info button it
said spoiler they don't find it yet
another season yeah I'll be not lying in
bed watching CNN I was watching CNN hit
the info button and it said the kid from
a Christmas story angrily backs away
questions while wearing an Oshkosh
B'gosh husky boy soon
watching the The Real Housewives of
Atlanta yeah
and then I hit the button and it said
tonight we've got more than 250 oh no
you didn't watching the show Family
Jewels yeah hit the button it said hey
look it's our next president very
possible watching the show flip or flop
and then I hit the button and it said I
know I shouldn't be telling you this but
here's how the entire season plays out
flip flip flop flip flop flop flop flop
flop clip clop clop clop clip clop clop
clop clip clop clip and flop yeah
and finally t-spin I was watching c-span
hit the button it said watch people no
one will have sex with decide and who
you can have sex with
you